well for more on what that means we go
tonight to the single most
informed source that we're aware of on
this topic louis elizondo ran the
pentagon ufo task force he joins us
tonight
lou thanks so much for coming on so
tucker
first what what do you take from this
what have we learned
well this is certainly a historic moment
for us for our country and i think
uh for our military and our intelligence
community the the government has
formally and officially come out and
informed congress that
these things are a they're real and two
that
they're not ours uh and that they seem
to be performing at least some of them
as you say in remarkable ways and i i'll
i'll tell you something else that i find
very interesting
you mentioned it out of the 144 cases we
only only were able to solve one but
there's there's two sub notes to that
and the first one is when you look at
this report very carefully you'll notice
that really the reporting only began
in around uh the march 2019 time era
when
when the navy established its reporting
requirements and then later on
in november 2020 maybe about eight
months ago with the air force
so we have 144 reports
really concentrating in just the last
year and a half
involving only military equities and
then the report further stipulates that
a large majority of reporting really
goes unreported why because of stigma
and taboo which is something that you
and i are both
very familiar with involving this topic
so one can surmise that there's actually
a lot more than just 144 incidents
involving the navy in just the last year
and a half let alone as you say
since the late 1940s
so the report all but says what is
obvious to anyone who thinks about this
which is these are not from a foreign
military and maybe the lackadaisical
approach or this organized approach
on the part of the military to looking
into this suggests that too
if we thought these were chinese you
know we'd be on it
and so we don't think they're chinese
they're not chinese and they're not
russian so they're extraterrestrial i
mean what's the other
i mean let's just let's just say it
what's the other explanation
you know tucker that that's that's a
fantastic question because as we've said
before when i was an aten
this is something that could involve
outer space inner space or frankly the
space in between
and that's why we've always said let's
keep all options on the table the more
we learn about quantum physics and this
remarkable universe we live in
the more we realize that our that our
current understanding of the construct
of the cosmos
uh is is constantly changing it's
constantly evolving with with new
information new knowledge that we get
i think from from this report's
perspective if you notice the very first
line
in the report is this is a preliminary
report
which is indica indicative of the fact
that hopefully there will be
other reports forthcoming um in the
report they stipulate that we need a lot
more effort going into this this needs
to really be as as we've been saying
a whole of government approach not just
the military not just the intelligence
community
but as we see here ffaa perhaps nasa
department of homeland security we could
even go into the for
for example the academic and scientific
communities like the national science
foundation
and maybe establish something that looks
something like like a federal lab
construct
we can really get the best and brightest
to really look at this
this incredible enigma we're now facing
well yeah and it's a testament to how in
curious our leaders are that we haven't
done that
like decades ago but back to my previous
question
is there in your view without
speculating as to i guess what these
might be let's just
take off the table what we we're pretty
sure they're not
i mean they can't be human can they and
if they are i mean
if these were human which humans would
be doing this
yeah it's looking uh increasingly like
this this is
probably not the case but the question
is what is it and of course people
jump to speculation from the pleiades or
something like that when in fact
one of the hypothesis when i was in a
tip was that this this could be as
natural to earth as we are
we're just not a point where where
technologically we're advanced enough
where we can begin to actually collect
information on it
and begin to to try to figure out what
it is there's been other hypothesis that
the things are possibly from underwater
and as outlandish as it may seem uh
these are
there are there is some anecdotal
evidence that supports you know all of
these observations so
again what we want to do is try to get
as much data on the table as we can
before we start eliminating what
something
oh of course but let me let me
just rephrase it without getting into
all the theories about you know if it's
not human then it is something
i have no idea but i'm just fixated on
the idea that
given the data we now have
it doesn't seem like these could be
human have you heard or from a human
source have you heard
anybody offer up a plausible explanation
for how
human beings could be responsible for
these sightings
no and i'll share with you even a little
bit more insight when i've had my
private communications with some of my
former colleagues and some people that
are that are still in washington dc
uh the conversation that these being
non-non-human vehicles and controlled
vehicles but still intelligently
controlled by something or
someone is certainly not off the table
uh these are conversations that are
absolutely occurring
uh but but again because as the report
stipulates because of stigma and taboo
um no one's having this conversation
really publicly yet in fact if you read
i think it's probably towards the end of
the report
they say that our airmen still don't
even want to have this conversation with
colleagues
because they fear fear retribution and
and that's
that's part of the problem having this
conversation
yeah this is becoming a country where no
one can say anything that's obvious
and saying the obvious is a prerequisite
for thinking
and for advancement and so i'm so i'm
just so glad that you do
you're one of the few